qui prive les Haïtiens.. d'eau
potable et de carburant.
Gabrielle Proulx
(tumulte)
- Le premier ministre d'Haiti,
Ariel Henry, lance un appel
à
catastrophe humanitaire.
(tintamarre)
Il demande, entreararararararax
le déploiement immédiat
d'une force armée
spécialisée en Haïti.
(tirs) A A A A A A A A A A A AÀs
criminels contrôleraient 90 %
de la capitale, Port-au-Prince,
et ses banlieues, dont
les
ravitaillement en essence,
faisant grimper les prix des
denrées les plus essentielles,
comme l'eau et les médicaments.
maintenant été confirmés,
dont sept décès.
C'est une question de temps
avant que la maladie se propage
de façon exponentielle,
selon les Nations unies.
-  I
planification...
- Un an et demi après
l'assassinat du président
Jovenel Moïse, l'enquête piétine
politique et sociale du pays
s'aggrave. Et certains jugent
que le premier ministre actuel
est dépassé par les événements.
du premier ministre est un acte
de faiblesse, est un act
de son échec.
- Bien ça va rester comme çamame
que, nous, on n'a pas de
la commande des pouvoirs
restent à Washington.
- Est-ce qu'ils vontaiaire
quelque chose? Ça fait longtemps
là, ça continue encore.
historien, CIDIHCA
- Je crois queononsieur Henry
est en train de penser que seule
une intervention étrangère peut
provisoirement au pouvoir,
soit de uvuvoir lui-même ne pas
être victime de cette situation
dans laquelle il a entraîné
- Reste à voir si des
rtrtenaires majeurs comme
les États-Unis et le Canada et
la France répondront présentsaie
sur le terrain, alors que
la guerre en Ukraine continue
de retenir beaucoup l'attention.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx, M M M M .